the president
good morning
dear colleagues the
sitting is open
one announcement in relation to the
decisions by several committees to enter
into
inter-institutional negotiations
pursuant to rule 71. paragraph one
announced at the opening of the session
on Monday the 13th of February I have
received no requests for a vote in
Parliament by members of political
groups reaching at least the medium
threshold the Committees May therefore
start the negotiations the next item on
the agenda is Council and commission
statements one year of Russia's Invasion
and War of aggression against Ukraine on
behalf of the council I give the flow to
the high representative Mr Burrell
Madam president
Madam president of the commission
they are members of the European
Parliament
I'm going to speak in Spanish
and while you are using your headphones
I would like to use these first few
minutes to pay tribute to a president of
the European Parliament Mr hila Robles
who passed away a few days ago
uh staunch a pro-european
and he very much contributed to the
European project
ladies and gentlemen
today
I speak on behalf of the Council of the
European Union
in its General Foreign Affairs and
defense formation
um
I am at the helm so I am speaking from
the point of view of governments the
intergovernmental perspective and that's
one of the pillars that underpins the EU
and after that the president of the
European commission will be giving the
uh Community point of view so I'm going
to try to make sure that I don't say the
same thing twice but as I as high
representative for uh foreign and
security policy
we are interested in the measures taken
by member states and then of course the
commission's foreign policy so we have a
dual function we've got external policy
and security and defense which aren't
the same even though one follows on from
the other very often and the war in
Ukraine has highlighted the importance
of the common defense and security
policy so it's been a wake-up call for
Europe
a geopolitical wake-up call and as
Chancellor Schultz said a few days after
the invasion
this has been and I'm going to mangle
this probably in German there's been a
shade and wind
so this hasn't just been for Germany but
it's been for the whole of Europe a
wake-up call before a new reality a new
reality for us which was war
and it is something that wasn't on our
intellectual Horizon because we had
dropped our guard and what proves that
is the fans that are defense stockpiles
were very low and our defense
capabilities were low as well and our
capacity to react uh wasn't what it
should have been so
this has really sounded the alarm Bells
because it ushers us into a new world
because everything has become a
geopolitical debate and the European
Union has
responded in a way which is up to you to
judge and debate today I hope that this
debate will be used for this in order to
highlight what we've done you're aware
of what we've done I'm not going to
reiterate this so the representatives of
the peoples of Europe have to judge it
what else could we have done what have
we achieved
we have supported Ukraine militarily
economically financially diplomatically
as much as we have been able to we have
done a lot but in my opinion
it hasn't been enough I visited Ukraine
recently
where the president of the commission
and Commissioners attending the Ukraine
EU Summit
and once again I've seen people that are
defending their freedom and Independence
and leaders that are trying to deal with
this dramatic situation by taking the
European path president zielinski said
it here only a few days ago
the situation in Ukraine at the moment
is dramatic but the ukrainians are
looking towards Europe like so many
other peoples like mine did so in the
past seeing it as a promising future
it may be that the road is long because
the war
is long but we have to do everything we
can to make sure that this promise
becomes a reality we want Ukraine to win
the war
and then
I mean it belongs to the European family
anyway but we hope that we'll find in
Europe the future that it needs now the
reality on the ground is extremely
worrying at the moment more than 360
000 Russian soldiers are there twice as
many years before the war and the
Russian counter-offensive has begun even
if on a small scale and for the first
time Ukraine doesn't have the uh
Advantage the Edge by having more troops
on the ground so Ukraine has appealed to
the EU member states and all those who
help Ukraine and yesterday we met in the
Ramstein group with all those countries
that coordinate military aid to Ukraine
in order to take stock of the situation
to see what we've done what we've given
them as Aid and to also see what they
need more ammunition and more training
for Ukrainian troops in order to
continue showing that we will not Tire
in our efforts to help Ukraine
now uh I will say
that I like War as little as you do I'm
not a warmongering individual
I really do not like War
of course I prefer peace
as almost everyone or everyone there's
no point in reiterating this but what we
have to discuss is how to achieve peace
and to achieve peace we have to continue
supporting Ukraine militarily more than
we have done so and this is going to be
one of my key messages
now to achieve peace you need to win the
war and you can help Ukraine militarily
and at the same time in parallel make
all the Diplomatic efforts necessary to
ensure that peace comes as quickly as
possible these aren't Alternatives
they're not contradictory we have to do
both things in parallel we have to
provide more support and step up our
diplomatic efforts and very soon I'll be
able to plead this before the UN and ask
the Secretary General to start if he
wants a mediation process everyone has
failed up to now that whoever has spoken
to Putin has come back with a message
that he wants to continue this war until
he achieves his military goals
it would be ingenuous to ask for us to
stop providing military assistance so
that the work in last uh last time and
that peace will come about and I'm
saying I'm using the word ingenuous uh
not to use a stronger word now
because
if we do that the peace that we will
achieve will be a Russian Victory and
that will constitute a huge threat to
our security so what have we done what
has the council done I represent the
council here today
first of all it has adopted an
impressive package of sanctions in fact
nine and the tenth is on the way I'm
sure that the president of the European
commission will refer to it
now the aim is to weaken the Russian
economy and we have achieved this many
say that sanctions are inefficient and
that they haven't dealt a blow to the
Russian economy and that on the contrary
that they have caused problems here in
Europe it's true that the Russian
economy hasn't collapsed and that the
GDP growth isn't what had been forecast
and it's true that last year it got
extraordinarily High revenues that came
from oil and gas
but the situation is turning
thanks to our sanctions and thanks to
the oil price cap
if you look at the three key parameters
of an economy it's oil and gas revenue
and the Russian Finance Minister said a
few days ago that in January there are
46 percent lower than last year
so yes they raked in a lot in 2022
because price is hiked they soared
and we still depended on them but we no
longer depend on them one of our great
successes has been to reduce our
extraordinary dependence energy
dependence on Russia to almost zero now
so 46 percent less January to January
and if you look at the public deficit
it's 40 time 40 times higher in January
2023 compared to January 2022 14 times
our
so from 2 billion to 1.8 trillion and if
you look at the trade balance you'll see
that yes they had a huge Surplus in 2022
because of uh bumper uh wheat crop but
in January 2023 it's a at a record low
at a historic low uh since 2007 so
oh
the sanctions are a low action poison a
little bit like arsenic it takes time to
bring about effects but they are they
have had an impact 45
of Russia's technological dependencies
on Europe uh their plane and car plants
have lost 80 percent of their capacity
yes the ruble is strong artificially but
the Russian economy is going to pay a
very high price for this war they have
lost their main energy client the
Europeans and they will not get them
again and it's not going to be easy it's
going to be almost impossible to find an
alternative client for Russian gas
because China is too far and oil is
being
sold at forty dollars a barrel in other
words half the Brent crude oil price
India and China buy it at this lower
price and that is also because of the
impact of our price cap which is a huge
political success because it has a
greatly slashed the Russian Revenue but
not uh had a negative impact on the
World Market so our measures are having
an effect it's happening slowly but
surely but they are undermining the
industrial and unenergy Bedrock of the
Russian economy Putin has already lost
the energy battle in the same way as he
is losing the war ethically and morally
and even militarily militarily even
though Ukraine hasn't won yet the second
thing the council did apart from
adopting these package of sanctions uh
put forward by the High representative
and the president of the commission
working hand in hand and let me thank
the president of the Year commission for
her leadership and energy we have also
provided weapons to Ukraine yes for the
first time the EU hasn't used resources
from its budget but has used resources
from the member states in order to arm a
country in war at war and if you put the
European peace facility amount together
with what member states have done
bilaterally we're talking about a total
of uh 12 billion Euro and the total
amount of assistance is 60 billion no
one has done more than Europe to help
Ukraine in financial and economic terms
and our military aid might be less than
the us but it is not a negligible amount
yesterday at Ramstein I said something
which I would like to repeat here not
only do we have to continue the
assistance we provide but we've got to
step it up and I'd like to put forward a
plea to those countries that have modern
and efficient battle tanks and that are
just Gathering dust in their in their
Depots and aren't being used to give
them to Ukraine and to provide them to
Ukraine as quickly as possible
because this spring and upcoming summer
are going to be decisive the war will be
decided in the spring and summer and we
have spent too much time discussing
whether we were going to provide the
famous leopard tanks while Russia Was
preparing its offensive we've spent too
much time discussing decisions that
should have been taken before we were
fearful that getting involved in the war
would be seen as pseudo belligerence but
we said that we would provide battle
tanks and the third world war hasn't
broken out yes the tanks aren't there
and is going to take time for them to
get there but time is crucial and time
is measured in in lives lost so
it's extremely important to focus on the
European peace facility and to
coordinate the work done by the member
states and to ask for more and more Aid
to be provided more quickly this is the
key message I want to put across this
morning but let me reiterate the idea
that this military assistance
is not contradictory to seeking peace
diplomatically it doesn't fly in the
face of that one can go in parallel with
the other I don't understand those who
say that to negotiate we've got to stop
providing military assistance to Ukraine
on the contrary both have to be done
together
this isn't
um a debate between doves and Hawks this
is based on realism knowing the reality
on the ground and what we have to and
must do
and this is also
an alarm Bell Europe has to understand
that we need a higher defense capability
than we have our
defense industry has to be stronger
the ability of our armies to deal with
this kind of situation has to be greater
because we've seen that it's fallen
short of what was necessary this war is
going to be long
and we've got to tackle this based on
the conviction that a war of attrition
is a logistical battle it's a battle of
logistics it's a battle of uh in
information
because if you
you look at those who are in Sahel we're
talking about the same groups in Ukraine
the Wagner group they're both in the
Sahel and in
Ukraine so there's the issue of the
minerals and geopolitics and we need to
face a situation geopolitically this is
also the job that you have to do ladies
and gentlemen honorable members we've
got to convince Europeans that we cannot
flag that war comes at a cost but
Freedom come has to we have to pay the
price for Freedom as well and the price
that we're paying is small compared to
what others are paying Putin cannot win
this war
Ukraine has to win this war in order to
build stable peace in Europe thank you
the high representative I know
to the president of the European
commissioner Russell love on the line
thank you very much Madam presidential
Balta on
hrvp my dear Joseph honorable members
it's now almost a year ago on the night
of February 24th that Russia invaded
Ukraine and War was back to Europe
that night I think all of you remember
that our thoughts and I think also our
prayers went to our friends in Ukraine
I remember vividly how we followed the
news from the donbass and kief with
unbearable tension
and we all were wondering whether the
Ukrainian friends would be able to
withstand the onslaught of the Russian
Invaders
today we know yes they would
one year on Putin's perfidious plans
continue to be foiled by the brave
Ukrainian Nation
one year on Russia has completely
alienated itself from Europe
it's most important economic
relationship and is isolated on the
global stage
one year on
this very Parliament last week welcomed
the president of Ukraine volada
mizalenski as a true hero he is
and one year on
poutine's Imperial fantasies have woken
up to oblique reality while Ukraine's
dreams of Freedom are stronger than ever
and they will prevail I'm deeply
convinced
honorable members what a difference one
year of unity
and resolve can make
in the early hours of February 24th when
Russian tanks rolled into Ukraine a
whole continent was holding its breath
some predicted that Ukraine would fall
in a matter of days
but instead the legendary bravery of the
Ukrainian people stunned the world
their Fierce resistance at the gates of
Kiev
the civilians who stopped Russian tanks
in the south
the counteroffensive of Ukraine's armed
forces in Carson
we can never match the sacrifices and
The Bravery of the Ukrainian people
but what we can do is stand firmly by
their side and that's what we've done
from day one on and we will continue to
do that they can rely on us
and indeed a whole continent has
mobilized from the volunteers of the
Warsaw station you remember who welcomed
the ukrainians fleeing Putin's bombs
basically to all citizens and companies
who have cut their electricity demands
together with you
honorable members
we have focused on three main goals
first
to support Ukraine's resistance against
the inviver invader unwaveringly
second
to undermine Russia's War Machine
and third
to build Ukraine's European future
together
and these three strands of action have
guided us over the last year and will
continue to guide us in the months to
come
on
I would like to express our steadfast
support to Ukrainian resistance since
the start of the war we've provided
economic humanitarian and Military
Support
to the tune of 67 billion Euro
we have a budgetary support for military
capacity humanitarian aid aid to
Ukrainian refugees
all this is a tangible contribution to
Ukraine's war effort
Putin wanted to see the Ukrainian State
collapse we have helped Ukraine to
remain operational even in its Darkest
Hour Europe
breathed impetus into Ukrainian
resistance and we will continue to
support it we guarantee a constant flow
of financial aid
the first part of the package the 18
billion has already been dispersed to
Ukraine we will continue to provide
steadfast predictable support every
month that is what Europe promised and
we have honored our pledge
Europe also supports Ukrainian companies
and workers who continue
to work despite the war we are using the
single Market to that end we have
integrated markets twined our towns and
offered our electricity networks ensured
solidarity corridors so that Ukraine can
export its goods around the world
that represents 20 billion in revenue
for Ukrainian companies during this
period of war and we can do more
when we visited Kiev we agreed on a road
map
to further improve Ukraine's access to
our single Market
Putin wanted to kill off Ukraine's
Europe European dream now Ukraine is
moving far more swiftly and resolutely
towards Europe
at the same time
we are weakening Russia's ability to
keep its War machinery
in place we have adopted nine packages
of sanctions the Russian economy is
shrinking
we need to keep up the pressure and
we're suggesting a tenth tranche of
sanctions with trade Bans
and new checks on exports to Russia
exports of Technology we're talking
about 11 billion Euro
we are suggesting restrictions on some
dozen electronic components used in
Russian armed systems such as drones or
missiles and helicopters
there are also hundreds of drones
manufactured in Iran used by Russia in
the battlefield in Ukraine these Iranian
drones kill Ukrainian civilians and it
is appalling
and so for the first time we're also
suggesting
sanctions targeting
Iranian economic operators including
those linked to the Revolutionary guard
it is our duty to do that to sanction
such Behavior
Putin is assuming that our support for
Ukraine
will not last the course he thinks it
would be easy to
blackmail Europe because at the time at
the start of the war we were heavily
dependent on Russian oil and gas but he
got that one wrong
one year on from the start of the war
he has lost the energy war that he
himself triggered we have adapted turned
to Reliable partners and we can see the
results
Russia's revenue from sale of oil and
gas in particular gas to Europe
has dropped by two-thirds we have uh
introduced a global oil price break
or cap and that
has lost led to losses each day of 160
million for Russia gas prices in Europe
are currently lower than before Russia
invaded Ukraine in Europe we are now
investing in clean energy and energy
Independence
we are looking at renewable energy
sources and breaking records wind solar
energy for example last year we
generated more energy and electricity
through wind and solar than through gas
we showed uh Resolute phase uh smart
Savvy policies and so in Europe we
resisted Russian blackmail and pressure
and have ensured greater energy
Independence our economies are doing
better
we have been able to correct our growth
forecasts upwards however Kremlin has
had to sell off gold reserves
to plug the gaps caused by dropping
fossil fuel Revenue ladies and gentlemen
Putin's attempt to Blackmail us has been
a staggering failure and that is good
news
ladies and gentlemen honorable members
president zielinski
has often discussed
this with me he has talked about
how people in Ukraine
deal with and cope with the horrors of
War despite what happened in European
and butcher
what provides them with hope after
seeing mariopol and other cities bombed
so what gives them hope it is that firm
belief that the future of their country
the future of their children lies with
the European Union
that is our third task
we want
to offer the ukrainians a bridge towards
hope to move from the horrors of War
towards a better brighter future in our
midst
and its progress on the past towards our
Union go hand in hand
you've heard it from president zielinski
in this very hemicycle
I've seen it with my colleague my
college in Kiev
I know it from the colleagues at the
commission that they confirm it every
single day
ukrainians are making tangible progress
despite the war despite fighting the
aggressor they know that the accession
to our Union is a merits-based process
they have passed legislative reforms
that others thought would take years
they are making this progress because
they are striving for Europe with all
their heart and soul
Ukraine as a nation defined not only
by its history
and Heritage
it is a nation defined by its dreams
and Europe is one of these dreams
so distinguished members
let's honor these dreams
by standing up for Ukraine for as long
as it takes so that one day
the representatives of the Ukrainian
people
will have their place in this very
hemicycle long live Europe slavery
Ukrainian
thank you very much
the president of European commission and
now we start with the representatives of
the different political groups starting
with the president of the Epp group
Mumford Weber
president metzola president president
almost one year of unimaginable
suffering one year of Bloodshed and one
year of Destruction for Ukraine and
Ukrainian people seven thousand innocent
children women men have been killed
many of them died in hospital schools in
their homes
at the hand of Putin's Army over 8
million ukrainians fled their country
their home looking for a safe haven in
Europe
this is a reality that ukrainians have
been waking up to every day since 24th
of February last year since
357 days
it was a historic moment for Europe when
President zelensky was with us last week
in the European Parliament and I want to
thank Roberta our president for inviting
him for managing this a touching moment
for all of us but also an important
message one year ago when we saw him on
the screens we didn't know
can he survive can Ukraine confront
Russia successfully and yes president
zielinski his army also just and his
over 40 million compatriots Stand United
and they were until now successful they
show us what it means to follow the
European way of life
our Ukrainian friends show us every day
what it means to be European they show
us if people have a choice they choose
democracy over outcracy rule of law over
rule of fuel and freedom over tyranny
and that is called
the European way of life
president silenski was using this Frame
around 20 times in his speech last week
and allow me to remind us how much
socialists and greens have been fighting
against the special portfolio inside of
the European commission last time
to promote and protect the European way
of life
as Epp we fought for it and today I have
to say it is the headline it is you
don't want to hear this but is he
headline of President silensky and
probably the motivation for our
Ukrainian friends the European way of
life and we should be proud about this
Roberta metzola as our president was the
first to risk to go to Kiev
we are on your side that was the main
message of Roberta and it was the left
on the line was leading to Grant the
candidate status to our Ukrainian
friends and let's be clear this was not
welcomed so much by Schultz by macron by
Sanchez or by Costa that's why I want to
thank our two presidents for her leading
role in the historic moment to keep
Ukraine on our side
for us as Epp it has been clear from the
very first moment we stand beside our
Ukrainian friends who seek live and
defend the European way of life Putin
wants to destroy this he's the opposite
he hates it
his dictatorship stands for suppression
censorship war crimes totally tourism
the Putin war is a Putin is a war
criminal and he must lose this war
this war has shaken Europe at its core
but Europe has been United and stronger
than ever before we imposed
unprecedented sanctions which will
weaken Putin's War Machine and we
welcome very much the new proposals now
we support the Ukraine with around 50
billion 65 billion was your figure on
for financially humanitarian and
Military Support
we send weapons now finally also tanks
and I would say there is one still open
question on the table and that is about
building up a real European defense
capability
High representative mentioned it but
there is not so much on initiatives
currently on the table to do so
and finally
there cannot be and let me use a
historic comparison there cannot be any
kind of Munich event in the next years
in front of us we are democratic police
politicians accepted
to split up Czechoslovakia for getting
peace or at least the dream of Peace the
future of Ukraine will not be decided in
Berlin in Paris and Brussels or
Washington only ukrainians decide about
the future of Ukraine we will not let
them alone in their Fight For Peace and
Freedom to fight to leave the European
way of life Slava Ukraine
how I give the floor to Pedro Marcus on
behalf of the snd group
[Applause]
thank you madam thank you madam
president Hi representative Madam
president of the commission dear
colleagues
one year of the brutal Russian war of
aggression against Ukraine
it resulted in the death of thousands
and thousands of innocent lives
the destruction of a country millions of
refugees increased in security and
suffering free Europe and the world
do you stood by Ukraine for all of this
time we will continue to support them
for as long as it takes ukrainians can
count on our political diplomatic
humanitarian financial and Military
Support
Putin from his side can count with our
strong Resolute and increase sanctions
as it was just proposed today which we
thank to drain its power
now our unity in the support of the
ukrainians has proven to be one of the
biggest strengths against the Russian
aggressor
that is why it is so concerning for this
Parliament I would say I would hope for
this Parliament as a whole but
unfortunately not that some in the ranks
of the Epp are now
trying to put things the other way
around
it was appealing to hear Mr Barlow's
Corning
excusing Putin from his responsibilities
and blaming Ukraine for this war
we have seen yes it was
I thank you for your applause Mr favor
it's important that you do so but let me
be clear also on this you just said
we'll defend the European way of life
for the ukrainians good what concrete
actions will you take regarding Mr
berlusconing regarding this party Mr Mr
fever what concrete actions will you
take you have defended here with all of
us sanctions regarding those that have
supported Putin in this war what kind of
sanctions will start in your own
political family regarding Mr Berlusconi
so that we stand United We remain United
against the Putin aggression thank you
thank you I give the flow now on behalf
of the renew Europe group to Malika's
money
dear president dear president of the
commission their higher representative
their colleagues one year ago we lived
in a different world
and today we see Ukrainian families torn
apart because of Russia's war of
aggression
tens of thousands of people have died
and I would like to extend my
condolences to their loved ones
we all remember the images from butcher
a European Union key ring attached to a
lifeless hand
dear colleagues Ukraine's hope are our
objectives
one year on we see NATO strengthened
Ukraine is firmly in the center of our
European family
and we have to continue to provide
massive support to Ukraine also with
more military materials without the
booze
dear colleagues on the set anniversary
we need to show our determination
we need to be United
in this house
also
a reaction to Mr Webb on behalf of the
Epp our voice needs to be United
especially today a year after this huge
strategy the starting of the war in
Ukraine dear colleagues let us expand
the EU sanction list to 6 000 Russia
individuals let us hold Russia
accountable to the Tribunal for the
crime of aggression in The Hague and let
us use the confiscated Russia funds to
start rebuilding Ukraine as soon as
possible
thank you Mr osmania and now I give the
floor to the co-president of the green
group Terry reindica
thank you for president
thank you president dear colleagues a
year after the brutal escalation of the
war in Ukraine its plain that we are
firmly on the side of the assailed
Democratic State Ukraine and our support
to be it Financial or political albeit
military is absolutely set in stone
even if in my home country we keep
hearing people trying to propagate crude
and cruel narratives in order to
undermine the public debate
providing weapons to the ukrainians will
not prolong the war that's what poutine
is doing what
weapons support ukrainians had prevent
the Ukraine as being annihilated and
prevent them from being occupied
as the high representative said
delivering weapons does not to preclude
negotiations
supporting a country to defend to itself
does not mean you are forsaking uh the
diplomacy you are in fact supporting
international law I think it's important
that we make this plane in the debate we
will not talk back to the status quo not
with the correct Russia the entire
security situation in Europe has changed
dear colleagues a new world requires
fresh answers not old responses so
rather
than just pilluring the people
Germans and others need
to look in their own backyard before
pointing the finger at and pillaring
other member states a new world means we
must support and continue to stand by
the side of the Ukrainian we want this
new world I am going to give the floor
on behalf of the ID group to Yak Madison
thank you madam president good morning
colleagues first of all when I heard
from
our representative that it was a wake-up
call what Russia did one year ago I was
really surprised that are we really born
yesterday I think the war started
already nine years ago 2014 and it isn't
surprise that Russia has ambitious
to go back to the history in the Soviet
Union times
and they very clearly stated that in
December 2021 when they asked impossible
things that there were no new NATO
member states that there would be like
some kind of puppet countries next to
the Russian border like Ukraine Finland
Sweden that they are not allowed to join
with nature and also they asked that if
you don't do like this we as we are
asking
and they asked that all the native
troops have to leave from the NATO
member states like Poland Estonia Latvia
in this case we will attack you I think
it wasn't surprised it was clearly
visible for last 30 years
when the Socialist socialist colleagues
were attacking Epp colleagues here I
should remind you that unfortunately
unfortunately your friend in the German
government and Mr Schultz is blocking
more military aid
they're waiting his signature to send
tanks and now one year later they're
like oh we have to check in which
conversation we have for thanks one year
later and now they're checking for the
condition for tanks really surprising
2014 when the war started already it was
a problem for the Germans to continue
with Nordstrom too it wasn't a problem
at all no let's go further it's just a
economic relation there is no economics
without politics
same thing with Americans
ukrainians asked the fighters already in
March last year and Americans were
blocking that Poland said we will give
our old Russian fighters to Ukraine just
please send us F-16 Fighters Americans
were no no we are too afraid no maybe we
escalate the conflict
the fact is weakness is provocation our
weakness is provoking Russia to go
further thank you and that's historical
facts so don't be weak don't be too
pro-russians act now and fight now and
win this war thank you I give the floor
next on behalf of the ECR group to bayat
ashidwa
Madam president
uh
the ladies and gentlemen
the Ukraine is defending peace in Europe
and it is our duty as Europeans
to stand arm and arm with them and
support them because it is
also giving thanks for the Ukraine have
has done for us
it is our duty to support Ukraine
politically economically Humanity in the
humanitarian way and in a military way
uh we need to take quick and important
decisions there is no room for positive
calculation
let's remember the events that
preceded The Invasion
2008.
Polish president
in Georgia said clearly
when Russia attempted to attack Georgia
he said today Georgia tomorrow Ukraine
and later maybe Poland has anybody drawn
any conclusions from that no
there was still cooperation with Russia
Putin was received in Europe
there was a reset in the relationship
with Russia
polish prime minister Donald Tusk spoke
with Putin black equals
economical projects like North stream 2
before not stream one
kept being implemented there was an
attempt to reset the political
relationship with Russia and then 2014
were there conclusions John no
the former German Chancellor
has a seat on the board of gaspram
there was still a policy of promoting
economic relationships with Russia I'm
not accusing I'm just saying that we all
need to learn our lessons from the past
we need to support Ukraine just as other
member states
do it because we know that a Ukrainian
Victory is a victory for us all I'd like
to thank all the Europeans who have
opened their hearts to ukrainians
I have to underline uh the role of the
Polish people of the Polish president
anjay dutand of the Polish government
Ukraine must win and we must keep
supporting Ukraine and we must keep
learning lessons
in order to prevent any such aggression
Europe to happen in the future again
thank you very much the left group Mick
Wallace
president Mr representative
Russia is a legal invasion of Ukraine is
Unforgivable
the devastation debt under Street
stabilization wrought by it has led to
Unthinkable Horrors as in all wars
also unforgivable is how willing Western
leaders are to ensure this becomes a war
Without End
instead of calls for ceasefires dialogue
and peace talks we are deepening Western
involvement in the war with no apparent
concern for the repercussions
we are calling for Ukraine to take back
Crimea experts on both sides of the
ocean say that this was Madness and will
lead to a possible breakout of nuclear
war
and it will also rally the Russian
people towards the defense of Crimea if
we go to that space
zelinski has been making the rounds
begging for more weapons but now one
word to say about peace
and many of his own people must he
conscript and feed into the Carnage
before he sits down to negotiations
and in many of the people of Europe must
lose their jobs and our homes before
NATO would allow these noises
negotiations to happen
and lastly
what I'd like to know what has happened
to Germany the jewel of Europe
Schultz told us that to be no peace in
Russia no peace in Europe without Russia
first you send helmets
now you're sending tanks to kill
Russians I worry for Europe
[Applause]
I give the flow now to Marcel the Graf
four seaters president the West
is weaponizing Ukraine has been doing so
since 2014 since Yen stoltenberg became
Secretary General of NATO
as of 2014 Ukraine was shooting and
killing russian-speaking citizens in its
country
we need to put an end to racist violence
this war has been triggered by the west
and the reasons are clear
Russia stands in the way of a U.S
ambition it seeks to remain independent
retain its identity the EU is in a bad
position here it has been hard hit by
its own sanctions the economic Outlook
is poor North stream has been blown up
by the U.S
the
Commission
needs to consider its role in this
terrible attack and talk to no way about
this put it into sanctions we need to
work on peace rebuilding economy
identity and sovereignty of member
states thank you we've never China
Ukraine
thank you Ukraine thank you for
defending peace
what would Euro be like if Putin had
taken over Ukraine in three days as he
planned yes it was horrible one year
however it would be much worse if the
infection of putinization took over a
large part of the European continent
today Ukraine is winning this war but it
depends on us how fast the size of
Ukrainian Victory will be achieved a
year ago ukrainians got not scared
fending of terrorist Russia we are safe
behind Ukraine's shoulders and we also
should not be scared
we must provide Ukraine with everything
they need air defense systems fighter
jets tanks long rage missiles we must
deliver an opening EU membership
negotiations as soon as possible this
year we must not repeat the Bucharest
NATO Summit mistake we must invite
Ukraine to join NATO at Vilnius NATO
Summit this year our bravery will bring
the victory faster and save many
Ukrainian lives this can also bring
change in Russia itself but we must not
be afraid of the fall of Putin's regime
I didn't want to say this what I will
say now today but I have to yes
Berlusconi is horrible but he is not
alone
socialist Schroeder socialist presidents
of Croatia Bulgaria socialist leader in
Slovakia
let's condemn all of them
let's fight all proxies of Putin on our
own courtyards slavo crania
thank you next is Tony nopichula
thank you madam president Madam
commission president Mr High
representative
the ongoing political crisis in Moldova
shows us that Russia is not limiting its
assertive actions only to Ukraine
through this information and foreign
interference Russia is trying to provoke
a political crisis within European union
and along European borders
with one year since the start of the
Russian aggressions what are the lessons
we learned couple of them
that we need to continue supporting
Ukraine as long as it takes to defend
itself that we need to make our
sanctions more efficient and close all
the gaps that enable their evasion
that common foreign defense and security
policies cannot Remain the soft spots of
our integration
that we need to be strategically
autonomous when it comes to essential
Industries and services
that we need to continue working
together on reducing our energy our
dependence
that prioritizing trade and economic
relations without insisting on our
political values leaves Europe exposed
to the crisis
that we need more Europe to address all
these challenges Slava Ukraine thank you
Mr Pizza I give the flow now to pestras
a Petras
let's go ahead
Madam president Council and commission
Representatives the aquatics Russia's
Imperial chauvinism has triggered war in
Ukraine fuel tensions and instability
and condemned the Ukrainian people to
unprecedented suffering
for a whole year we have been hearing
lies slender and threats from Russia
those intentions remain unchanged ready
to continue the war in the near future
stopping an aggressive Russia means
defeating it on the battlefield in
Ukraine providing the Ukrainian with
everything and will enable them to
achieve Victory to shorten the war and
the suffering it has caused
dear colleagues
no one here wants to discuss a
resolution of two years of Russia's
Invasion and a war of aggression against
Ukraine
so let's help Ukraine with everything
that is necessary
let us continue weakening Russia
Russia's and Belarus work capacities and
let us punish the guilty according to
their and for forgivable crimes it's a
great historical moment and chance for
Europe to emerge stronger more united
and less dependent from authoritarian
regimes thank you thank you Mr
ostervichus now I give the float of you
a lot about them
president hrvp Burrell president of the
commission dear colleagues a year ago I
stood here warning putting that the
attack on Ukraine will be the end of
Russia as we know it that the imperial
overstretch would Doom Russian hopes of
regional domination the war that Putin
aimed to last three days has been now
waging for a year a dying Empire is
desperately trying to destroy the
Ukrainian State and identity but all
this is in vain because the brave people
of Ukraine are fighting not to conquer
but to defend not for Domination but for
survival
the unimaginable price ukrainians are
paying for Freedom keeps us all free
because Ukraine is defending us and
every democracy because the freedom that
some take for granted is never free it
is paid for by the sacrifice of brave
men and women
we do not need to be convinced Ukraine
is Europe and we all continue supporting
The Bravery for as long as it takes and
with all we have thank you so much
thank you colleague
next up Harold vlimsky
thank you sir
thank you ladies and gentlemen
I listened carefully to what I said by
Mr zielinski last week in the plenary
I've got a couple of comments it's
rather strange that there was no debate
on this the parliament is the right
Forum to Bundy about our arguments and
exchange ideas
in order to find out what the best ideas
are
Mr zelenski according to the media just
handed
abandoned 100 list of who had provided
what equipment and weapons that's
barking up the wrong tree War can never
be a solution
I would like to stick up for a piece as
we all do Europe is based on the
principles of freedom and prosperity if
we take these ideas seriously
please play a role in the peace
negotiations to prevent her deaths in
the Ukraine we keep delivering weapons
and more and more people are perishing
so please be committed to peace
our next speaker is Anna fotica
president's High rep vice president
the alarm Bell we speak about since the
beginning of this debate is still on and
the war is not over
thousands of ukrainians
perish in in this war
and atrocities Russian atrocities
because of this criminal war of
aggression are are unbearable
Russia has to be defeated
the alarm Bell is still on for Ukraine
and for all of us
we have to to deliver whatever is needed
to to achieve this result now
everything fighter jets
fighter helicopters air defense systems
with appropriate range
we do this for us and our children we
have to know this
is
president
next week
will mark one year since the beginning
of Putin's war in Ukraine and peace is
not on the horizon
we talk a lot about providing weapons
but we don't talk enough about peace of
course it's not easy to achieve peace
but it should be our number one priority
Ukraine has the right to defend itself
and we have the duty to help ukrainians
defend themselves we have to defend
civilians that are the targets of
Vladimir Putin and that are the
potential victims of war crimes we have
to do everything in our power to make
sure that Ukraine can reconquer the
territories lost so that the war can
come to an end the longer the war the
more victims and we will feel the
effects over generations and we've drawn
our experience in Finland Ukraine needs
Aid on multiple fronts humanitarian AIDS
reconstruction Aid We're going to have
to start reconstruction as soon as
possible and the Reconstruction will
have to be funded by Russia too
[Music]
thinking about in the agendency
thank you Mr President dear colleagues
most of us are rightly appalled by the
official position of Hungary on this
conflict the pro-russian propaganda the
undisguised rooting for the aggressor by
prime minister Orban and the recent
visit of foreign minister Seattle to
Minsk while cynically talking about
peace with the aggressor and its Allied
regime however don't let that mislead
you vis-a-vis the Hungarian people
a majority of hungarians know that
Ukraine's fate today and our Legacy of
1956 are analogous
the story of both Nations fighting for
their freedom against Russian aggression
is the same and just like in 1956 when
official Hungary the regime rooted for
the Russians it was the voice of the
people that mattered and what the world
remembers today and finally while Europe
was numb and Silent to the Hungarian
cause delaying by decades the potential
reunification of our continent today it
understands the call of history and it
is also brave enough to act thank you
foreign
honorable members in nine days we will
Mark the first anniversary of Russia's
criminal act of aggression against
Ukraine we must take a moment to
commemorate the innocent victims the
children women men all those killed
raped and tortured and all the Ukrainian
soldiers who are fighting for a
justifiable cause defending their home
nation
we in the Europe need to stand with the
United West and do what is needed now
first things first we need to look at
weapons more weapons of fighter jets
artillery and tanks battle tanks not to
conquer new territory but to free
Russian civilians from Ukrainian
civilians from Russian oppression
those in my home country who are naive
anti-American or secretly have some sort
of
false perception of the historic
relationship between Germany and Russia
refused to deliver weapon weapons
they're refusing to recognize the
fascism in the Kremlin in the 21st
century never against lava Ukraine
our next speaker is a Sven mixer dear
colleagues this war will have to end
with every square inch of Ukrainian
Sovereign territory liberated
because otherwise if Russia should walk
out of this with territorial gains and
with a current regime still intact and
in power the international rules-based
order will have failed if not entirely
collapsed
I would like to underscore two points
made by higher representative Burrell
first implementation is commendable that
the decision was taken to donate tanks
but now those tanks would really have to
arrive and all countries who have
equipment to spare we'll have to step up
and secondly it is not simply sufficient
to continue supporting Ukraine military
but we will have to step up the support
significantly so as to turn the tide of
the wall and make sure that Ukraine
emerges Victorious
and very finally we should seek on this
release your unity in this house
deliberately heightening political
partner partisanship
is is irresponsible it's not helpful
it's not even elegant thank you
foreign
president
High representative
president zielinski came to ask for help
a few days ago one year after the
beginning of Russian aggression Europe
needs to wake up it is in our interest
for Ukraine to win and we have to do
everything in our power to make sure it
wins the war we have to do everything we
can means that we need to do more and
more quickly more weapons deliveries
more ammunition delivered those that
will give an edge to Ukraine
and help them when we mustn't
um dilly dally because there are lives
at stake
we also need to work to have sanctions
and make sure that no one tries to work
around the sanctions we those in Europe
who help Russia do that will have to be
threatened with secondary sanctions
we have heard please for immediate
negotiations but the Minsk agreement
failure should have inoculated against
the risk of Frozen conflicts those who
want appeasement those who want to
appease Russia should remember what
Churchill said
that those who uh peas are actually
feeding a crocodile hoping they will be
the last to be eaten thank you
next up bronis rocket
actually
thank you very much
and dear president
the commission president ladies and
gentlemen the Russian aggression in the
Ukraine started as far back as 2014 and
has only got worse because we fail to
prevent it
we wanted cheap resources and to do that
we forsook our principles we talked
about a strategic partnership and that
only assisted uh Putin in accumulating
resources for his aggression in the
parliament people keep claiming we are
not ready to reduce our dependence on
third countries
we are trying to find excuses for
sitting on our hands the time is right
so we have learned from our failures
if we want a Ukrainian Victory why are
we still Dilly dallying and delivering
arms give the ukrainians everything they
need let words become Deeds
thank you very much president a year ago
the red flags of the former Soviet Union
were being flown by the tanks entering
Ukraine this is an attack against the
territorial Integrity of a state Europe
had to take sides and we took the side
of Freedom sovereignty and the Dignity
of the Ukrainian people however 12
months later the risk that this could
become a permanent Frozen conflict is a
risk and we have to Ward this off for
the sake of Ukrainian civilians the
first victims and for our citizens and
companies that deal with price hikes and
higher bills could Europe have done more
to achieve peace if the solution to deal
with a conflict was to send more arms
why didn't we do it quicker
The Diplomatic solution and the
Diplomatic path is one we should take we
have to work together
uh the the class Stars doing well
doesn't mean that the whole class will
pass an exam once again Europe is
divided and that is really the
overarching aim of Putin
next one minute
one year from The Invasion we hear about
a new offensive by Russia we hear about
events in Moldova Putin is able to do
anything to reach just a small hint of
Victory and to be able to explain to the
Russians wide tens of thousands of
people had to die
we heard the head of uh the Wagner group
he said that he has plans to reach the
channel La manche if this doesn't make
us increase the aid to Ukraine I don't
know what Ellis would the Czech Republic
has already granted huge amount of
military aid and we will be continuing
to help going forward but we hear views
of some countries like Switzerland that
not only refuse to help Ukraine but they
actively block the aid of other
countries such actions have to be
refused
and we have to condemn those who are
able to sacrifice our security for a few
thank you Andrea bochko
Mr President ladies and gentlemen
Russia has been waging an illegal War
for a year
and we stand up for the territory
integrity and sovereignty of Europe at
all forums
uh War caused death and broke the dreams
of lives without irrespective of
nationalities and ethnicity Romanians
hungarians and other nationalities all
suffer from Russian aggression and they
fight for victory despite of all the
difficulties Ukraine continues on her on
its path to Europe and I hope that once
all
tasks are met all chapters are met then
we will be it will be able to join
Europe according to the set criteria
however the minority law is not in line
with the European laws therefore it
needs to be modified tragic pictures are
there on the screens everywhere but we
must not be tired of all these pictures
words must not be emptied out we need to
focus on peace
we could not prevent the tragedy of the
earthquake in Turkey but we can do a lot
for Ukraine thank you very much
it's yours
for ladies and gentlemen
a year ago
millions of women children and refugees
from Ukraine
ended up in Polish homes because there
was
a bandit attack on their country not the
first time in fact our immediate
reaction and our Firm Stance are still
insufficient because it is the
governments who hold the power
and as we heard there is no time why are
there even doubts on an embargo on
energy why are Russian companies still
operating in the European market
anyone who supports them is uh Putin's
Ally and helper
so I call for immediate action from all
governments all Ukrainian requests
should be implemented immediately
because it is the ukrainians who fight
for us and for the future and peace of
Europe so this is why we are obliged to
act so I'd like to ask Madam Wonderland
also to take care of Moldova this is a
country which is also suffering because
of this war and requires help thank you
very much
[Applause]
next up
Timo Savage
ladies and gentlemen and dear colleagues
Russia the Russian aggression is ongoing
it still has tragic consequences tens of
thousands of dead and a destroyed
economy
no one wanted this war no one wants this
war but we are all affected by it
we need to help Ukraine for humanitarian
legal reasons but also also for the
reasons of our own security ukrainians
are defending themselves and us as well
we here in this house calls for a
diplomatic solution
nobody ever mentions who and is going to
pay for this price and for this piece
and which prize uh yes negotiations are
a good solution but it's not always the
case in Munich France and the UK traded
the checks to that Inland uh for a year
of peace and a year later Germany
attacked Poland and then attacked France
as well
is the donbas any Crimea supposed to be
the sudet or not
uh do we want another aggressive country
to attack more nations in Europe we only
have one choice which is full support to
Ukraine which will stop the aggressor
thank you very much
thank you
very much
thank you chair Madam president dear
High representative of your colleagues
one year ago Russia unraveled the plan
which we now know was in the making for
many years
put in frustration with history went
back to USSR to the breakdown of
Yugoslavia to the Bucharest NATO Summit
and in general
to the moment when he looked himself in
the mirror and thought he was not big
enough for the rest of the world to fear
therefore he had to rewrite history at
any cost and for that he lied and he
killed and he'll continue to lie and to
kill until we give Ukraine the arms they
need to stop him
in direct contracts we heard president
zielinski speak to this house just last
week
we all saw his determination and
dedication to Ukraine's European popes
this is the type of leader that is big
enough
and not for the others to fear but to
follow and feel proud to bring at the EU
table
we must continue to support him match
his level of ambition when it comes to
EU integration and be bolder in our
actions be bold
like Ukraine is thank you
thank you hello
thank you chair commissioners
keep asking the question why this will
last so long the answer is simple
because money is still too many of those
who decide
care more about future faith of Russia
than about security of Ukraine it's a
paradox that the way
create peaceful and maybe democracy
Russia is to defeat Putin regime
the first step to achieve this goal is
to help you create not only to defend
itself but to defeat Russia free
Democratic Sovereign Ukraine member of
the European Union
will be the best message for the Russian
society that there is alternative way of
developing the country thank you
thank you
next up is
now a minute is as short as a minute of
Silence but if we were to have a minute
of silence for every one of Putin's
victims we wouldn't be saying anything
this morning and if we looked at the
list of Putin's victims it would take
more than four hours it would take more
than four hours this is a crime against
humanity and it's not happening at the
doorstep of Europe it's happening in
Europe Here and Now
today ukrainians are pro-european as the
French and German were after the second
world war and for the same reasons young
people are being told that there's no
peace without paying a price and that
Democrats and bring and they're being
told Democrats are saying that democracy
is built every day and that's also what
uh brexit score and there will be no
democracy until the Tyranny is trampled
upon that is why we are not going to
give up we know that Europe the war
might be drawn out but we cannot give up
and we will not surrender Slava Ukraine
thank you your colleague next up
jenskaya
president thank you very much
I representative
president to Dear colleagues
a few days ago many uh colleagues uh saw
the the first and of us around the
corner I Duff my hat to the bravery and
courage of the of the Ukrainian people
it is up to the EU and it does it
Burrell pointed this out that we
increased the will for Peace by giving
the ukrainians what they need funds
humanitarian Aid military assistance
I firmly believe that we should
emphasize that that we should take all
these things together what is the role
of all these demands uh that Germany
Supply weapons and many people in the
plenary are keen on this once the
preconditions have been laid down uh for
a common procedure for NATO Partners at
Germany is set to provide hundreds of
leopard tanks but what about our allies
the uh uh the German defense minister
said that this is
not to set to
set to happen
promises have been made
Norway under per Portugal maybe a
sitting but what about the rest we all
need to set our shoulders to where each
and every one of us if everybody does
that very uh best then they will show
that they are real allies and partners
in NATO all foreign
thank you president
commissioner High representative
almost one year on from the start of the
war in Ukraine we are seeing human drama
and much suffering
we feel the impact to only one
conclusion and I think
most previous speakers have said this
the only thing we can do in the face of
authoritarian regime
is to look to one solution we need
Ukraine to win and Europe must stick
firmly to its position we need to send
munitions uh ammunition tanks and
everything that Ukraine needs to Ukraine
and Europe
needs to stand firm
I hear some member states talk about
what they need to do for their own
defense we need to have a European
Defense Union not each going it alone
but a European Defense Market European
unity and we're working now on the 10th
package of sanctions
we'll have a look at problems here and
there now we have a list of 6 000 names
let's look at those 6 000 names let us
stand together and tell Putin that you
won't win the war you will never win
this war
and what is known how secret secret
Morrison
thank you very much Mr president
president found Airline High
representative one year after the start
of the war we have to say clearly thank
you to the people of Ukraine the fight
of the people of Ukraine is heroic it is
an inspiration to all of us it is an
inspiration to the Free World and we
have the duty to say thank you our
second duty is as long as the people of
Ukraine are fighting we have to help
them we have to support them with all we
can soon fast because between the time
we make a decision and the moment
support gets on the ground time passes
so we need to accelerate the speed of
our decisions the choice is not between
War and Peace war is a terrible thing
none of us likes War we all want peace
but the choice is between fighting or
surrendering and as long as the people
of Ukraine are fighting it is our duty
to stand by their side and it is also
our duty to tell to the people of Europe
that Russia is failing Russia is lose
using militarily economically
politically and morally Russia is
talking about an imperialistic past
which is long gone we are building
together a future for the people of
Ukraine for the people of Europe and we
are building it together that's the
difference thank you very much
thank you very much for our future
president team vice president
thank you very much president president
from The Lion High representative
Burrell a year on from the criminal
invasion of the Ukraine Putin has not
managed to make the Ukrainian people bow
the ukrainians are fighting for the
independence and the Very values of
democracy and freedom that we are keen
on all of our assistance has not managed
to Halt this aggression it beholds us to
ratchet up our support
we should find ourselves wondering what
the cost is to the Ukrainian people of
our dithering what is the cost uh to our
International credibility what is the
cost of the unfortunate words we heard
yesterday shameful words from Berlusconi
leveled at
zelenski I'm very ashamed as well as the
major resources
we have earmarked we also need to make
Brave political choices to punish
Putin's criminal acts against the
ukrainians we must support with every
possible means the territorial Integrity
of Ukraine and see to it that this
country has a future within our Union
next up Andreas kobilios
dear colleagues
this war can be stopped tomorrow
if Mr Putin will decide to withdraw his
troops from Ukraine however
since it is not realistic the only way
to end this International crime is to
defeat Russia in the battlefield
the first year of a brutal War has shown
that a combination of a highly motivated
Ukrainian Defenders and the Western
weapons are much stronger than the
Russian military capacity that is why
the delivery of the western weapons is
the most crucial factor which can bring
the end of this War I repeat it depends
only on the west how long this bloody
war will continue I am convinced the
West has all the possibilities to help
Ukraine to achieve its victory during
this year for that to happen Javas has
to stop being afraid of Russian defeat
impact on the future of Russia on the
contrary in order to have a sustainable
peace on the European continent Russians
need to be convinced to abandon their
Nostalgia to an Empire that will happen
if Russia will be defeated in Ukraine if
Putin will be brought to International
tribunal and if Ukraine will be invited
to join NATO slavo Greene
College
thank you colleague now we turn to catch
the eye
speakers
so please accept the one minute and I
have to see to uh
you can take so much as possible
I will start with Francisco Jose Milan
more
thank you very much
it's we've had one year of accrual and
unjust war in Ukraine but the sanctions
we imposed on Russia unfortunately last
you didn't have the effects we wanted
but let us hope that the oil measures
will do something this is a marathon not
a Sprint a low release poison as Mr
Burrell said he gave us figures showing
the slowing down of the Russian economy
this month however we haven't isolated
Russian economically there are states
that are helping you get the products
and goods it needs and that still buys
oil and gas and they have improvised and
come up with a fleet of cargo ships many
countries who have condemned the
aggression have to join the sanctions
but China in India contribute to
propping up the Russian economy I'm very
pleased that recently the European
Council committed to increasing the
measures in order to fight against this
we'll have to look at the U.N resolution
and its scope we we have to continue
weakening the Russian economy so it
doesn't fuel the war machine that wreaks
destruction and death
Aguilar president
of unfair and criminal War conducted by
Putin against the Ukraine but you have
to go back very many years to find a
parliament where there was a very broad
majority rallying behind the leadership
of
this Parliament has supported
humanitarian measures for displaced
people we have a supported the Strategic
autonomy and energy autonomy we need we
supported sanctions against Russia we
also provide Military Support to Ukraine
this is not war mongering there's no
contradiction in play here we are just
stressing that we Europeans are standing
up for peace and standing up to an
aggressor
we've spoke about a change of times a
site vendor in German the European Union
will tap into its leadership ability uh
to be more united when it comes to
common defense and security policy to
offset the social and economic costs of
the sanctions for the most vulnerable
people in the EU we
just we said we wanted a more perfect
Europe when we signed up to the Lisbon
treaty let's hark back to that
colleagues if you fail to stick to one
minute I cannot take all colleagues and
I will have to take five off the list
stick to time otherwise I'll have to cut
you off from the list
foreign
thank you president
for a year now Russia has been brutally
attacking Ukraine over the course of the
war the European Union and its Western
allies has shown unprecedented Unity
when it comes to imposing sanctions on
Russia and assisting Ukraine we need to
step up those sanctions for far too long
Europe relied on Russian energy and that
stymied any sanctions now we are
preparing a tenth package of sanctions
we do need to bolster them we need to
step up the pace of military aid
delivered to Ukraine particularly when
it comes to a heaven heavy weaponry and
tanks promises were made but those tanks
now need to be delivered swiftly the
Ukrainian people are fighting for
freedom and democracy they need our
assistance
we need to help Ukraine in its battle
and its path towards Europe
hello thank you giz royton
thank you president
um and thank you hi representative
Burrell for your leadership on this and
for your personal commitment in the past
years we have to stop to give Ukraine
just enough not to lose we need to give
Ukraine what it needs to win as soon as
possible that's our task not after the
summer not next month now we have to
stop the incrementalism on both the
sanctions and the military support So
now on the tanks I want to ask you hi
representative if you can take an
initiative to coordinate this because
since the decision about the tanks we
heard no not the least tanks no we have
some tanks in the mothballs that we want
to refurbish we need to coordinate this
in a European way in a European Spirit
to get these things as soon as possible
in Ukraine and to also use currently
operational used tanks for that matter
so I would be very appreciative if you
could take initiative on that thank you
and Slava krina
thank you Mr alexandrov Jordan of
Alexander
foreign
what have we learned for the last 12
months
one
military assistance when timely is more
relevant to peace than diplomacy two
peace is Possible only after the last
Russian soldier leaves your crane
three whoever speaks about peace today
is actually helping putting
for Mr Burrell your words were very
convincing today but those have to be
your words in Moscow a year ago
peace is impossible as long as Putin is
in Kremlin and finally I hope that the
Bulgarian Parliament will have worthy
members who will insist on an
impeachment of the pro-russian Bulgarian
president thank Marie
foreign
thank you very much
I would like to start off by
congratulating you Mr Burrell because in
your speech
you made this extraordinary statement
you uttered the word peace I don't agree
with those colleagues who say that if we
talk about peace we're helping Putin no
we're just making sure that they're less
victims let's think about the UN
Putin killed many people and I don't
agree with what we heard here when
speakers said that
weapons help weapons kill Mr Burrell
that's why we have to continue along
this path we have to make sure that we
continue our dialogue with NATO we have
to help the Republic of Moldova my
country shares a border with Ukraine we
need to help this country we need to
help Ukrainian citizens as Europe has
done we have to find a way to put an end
to this catastrophe
Demerol Islam is our next speaker
thank you president for a year we have
seen War ravage Ukraine for a year
people have been dying in Ukraine a year
of War fair is a year of a brutal battle
between NATO and Russia on Ukrainian
territory yesterday Mr stoltenberg said
that this war could have been forecast
back in 2014 that begs the question why
was everything not thrown at preventing
this war yes Russia did invade Ukraine
and should be condemned but what has
NATO done since then
it has uh stepped up
ammunition verbal and actual ammunition
what about peace negotiations uh the US
and others torpedoed and negotiations in
turkey last year so your behavior has
nothing to do with peace show real
solidarity with people in Ukraine stop
pursuing your geopolitical interests and
putting that above lives of individuals
thank you Costas Papadakis
for one year now the EU and member state
governments have said that the
imperialist war in Russia is a single
act play but it is actually part of the
clash between NATO U.S and the EU on the
one hand and capitalist Russia on the
other uh on the battlefield of
monopolies and the victims are the
Ukrainian and Russian people that for
centuries lived side by side during in
the Soviet Union
uh both sides are capitalists the Greek
Communist party has condemned
euratlantic interventions and the coup
in Ukraine in 2014 and the unacceptable
Russian invasion and is fighting hard in
order to avoid the new democracy
government involving Greece with the
support of syriza to make sure that
Greece isn't used as a NATO springboard
we need to disengage from euro-atlantic
interests and power thank you
foreign
thank you
likewise to the high representative
for his intervention this morning
I really do concur with the idea that
diplomacy is also a tool we can tap into
alongside the military assistance which
the Ukraine needs we must keep a bearing
in mind that the final goal is to
achieve a fair piece so the Ukraine
should win back its sovereignty and
territorial integrity
looking at today's Financial Times it
says Russia masses aircraft within
striking range of Ukrainian targets we
have not been quick enough to act
that the tanks and the fighter jets are
coming too late we don't know how long
the conflict will last this strategy
could have been even more efficient the
war has lasted a year and the Ukraine
has won back half of the territory
initially occupied by the Ukraine let's
do more and swiftly
foreign
thank you very much president when I
arrived in the European Parliament this
morning I thought I would find a full
chamber a chamber full of members of the
European Parliament listening to
speeches everyone focused on
reiterating and bolstering the position
of the European Parliament visa for
Ukraine in other words condemning
Russian aggression but so many
colleagues have decided not to take part
in this debate this chamber is very
sadly semi-deserted and some colleagues
prevented political controversy to a
deep reflection over what one year of
War means Forza Italia has always used
votes and actions to condemn the
invasion of Ukraine there isn't a single
act in this European Parliament that
shows anything different some socialist
colleagues instead of using the time
given to them in order order to speak
about the invasion of Ukraine used their
speaking time to attack Italy and
political leader such as Sylvia
Berlusconi they've made a mistake and I
hope they've understood that
one year from Putin's invasion is the
year of tragedy and sadness
Millions have fled their country and
thousands were killed brutally killed
like the 14 year old boy with his dog
killed during
a walk in Bahamut I got the photograph
from a photographer from my region who
is documenting the Russian crimes
uh vordenberg Klitschko said that this
is a civilizational war that Russia
treats Ukraine as something that is
worse
and that is why they want to destroy the
language the society and the culture we
do want peace I am a pacifist myself but
it is really difficult to be a pacifist
when such an unjustified war is taking
place just outside our borders the only
peace that we can accept in this
Parliament is a Ukrainian victory over
Russia and more weapons for Ukraine now
as long as it's not too late
Long Live a free Ukraine thank you very
much Katarina
Mr President I'm fascinated and we're
discussing such a topic of warning
Ukraine my colleagues in the Epp are
using it to attack us as political
opponents I believe we should talk about
things such as the sacrifice of citizens
of the EU who live at the border with
Ukraine for instance a citizens of
Slovakia Poland also Romania people who
open their homes offered help also
volunteered and very often these people
really didn't have much themselves and
yet they were willing to share this
little they own when the governments
were failing so I would like to thank
all these people for their help and I'd
like to mention them their contribution
I think it's important
um and I also believe that these people
do not want to talk about weapons they
want to talk about peace so I think we
politicians should talk about the fact
that the peace project that the European
Union is should be really significant
and to help Ukraine finish and end this
war because all those women and children
suffering day in day out is just oh will
now finish up catch the eye with Mr
olekash
yeah thank you chairman dear colleagues
most of us agree that EU and our partner
should increase and speed up support to
Ukraine as high representative you said
our military must include everything
that is needed for Ukraine to defeat
Russia Army and regain full control of
its territory including air defense
system fight adjust and long-term range
missile system as president of
commission said we need to implement new
sanction packet package but it's not
enough
they you also need to take a stronger
position on any individual or entity is
helping Russia to avoid imposed
sanctions any company new in that
country that is trying to profit from
the
War situation should be placed under
criminal investigation
at its asset-free and confiscated and
soldiers right to the in the court as
supporters of Terror at the same time we
must show that EU is ready to start
negotiation with Ukraine for accession
to EU process this year the echo Ukraine
slavo crane
well now move on to our second last
speaker on this item firstly the
commission representative Commission
sinkovichius
thank you president
hi representative honorable members
first of all let me thank this house for
today's debate and for your
interventions because this is an
important moment
an emotional one too
and a moment of determination
it was important to have this debate
today it gives us European commission
European Parliament and Council an
opportunity to strongly reconfirm our
full support to Ukraine to reiterate our
unconditional solidarity and to do
everything it takes
as long as it takes to undermine
Russia's War Machine
each of us
literally everyone
remembers where where we when we hear
the horrible news one year ago
I remember very well
I never imagined the moment in my life
that I will wake up my wife
and say the word started the first thing
we did we called our parents but by that
time they were already somewhere deep in
shelter I will never forget those hours
waiting for their reply unfortunately
those hours they will stick deep in me
for many many years
the 24th of February 2022 changed this
world
it changed each and every of us
and we would probably not have imagined
that we would stand here today
having this debate
357 days
into a brutal War
marupole Bahamut
once a thriving beautiful European
cities
today they don't exist
from the very beginning Putin's
condition for peace
so-called peace to wipe out Ukraine
their culture their tradition
their people
are you ready
to look Ukrainian children in the eye
and say rape loot
is their future because that would mean
that's the future of our children too
[Applause]
so let me say again
today's debate was important
as
we cannot repeat and reconfirm our
support and solidarity
often enough
any support of ours will never match the
sacrifice of Ukrainian Nation
president from the line
has made it very clear that we will
continue as long as it as it takes to
keep ukrainians dream of Freedom alive
to praise the legendary bravery of the
Ukrainian people to bring Ukraine closer
to Victory and closer to the European
Union where they truly belong
we continue to bring our markets closer
our towns and our cities
our people
we have built Bridges and we continue to
build more of them
building ukrainians European future
together
and reconstruction is going to be
another chance to show a true European
solidarity build Ukraine even back
better
Greener and stronger rebuild the beauty
of Ukraine
we need to lay the groundwork for a
green reconstruction holding Russia
accountable also for the all damage that
they have done and I truly hope that in
one year this debate will be about our
efforts to rebuild Ukraine
honorable members president from The
Lion has said it Ukraine's dreams of
freedom
are stronger than ever I can only
confirm this I can confirm this
personally
today's debate has sent a very strong
message we will help Ukraine so that
these dreams One Day become a reality we
will stand United will not only
not allow put into divide us
his attempts to divide us have failed
and we will make sure it will never
succeed because today has shown again
that we are united in our firm belief
that's Ukraine future
will be a European one
we own this Unity to Ukraine
to their children
and to our children too thank you
thank you female thank you
we'll now hear from the commission vice
president and high representative Joseph
Barrel fontelles
thank you
thank you vice president Carlos thank
you to all members that are following
this debate thank you colleague
vice president for this debate to have a
fully sense
I should be able to try to answer what
they heard from the members that have
intervened
because they have said very interesting
things
so I I asked for you
for your help if I take some minutes
more because I think I have to answer
and we have to share your views
otherwise it's not a debate
uh that's that's sweet to Spanish will
be quicker
some of you have said that we didn't
react after Crimea yes you're right it's
true
after Crimea we impose some economic
sanctions not too many
and we continued purchasing Russian gas
we continued increasing our dependence
on Russia and the continued building
Nordstrom it's true but you cannot
rewind history we're not going to solve
the problems of today by
self-flagellating over
problems committed in the past we have
to assume a responsibility and correct
them
and someone mentioned a shopping list oh
you've come here asking uh for uh tanks
Munitions and so on uh this is what you
said that President olenski did what
would you do you would go where you had
to go and ask for help and that's what
the assistants yes it's true that
weapons kill that's why they're made for
that and we know that we know that
unfortunately our military aid does lead
to a loss of lives but the problem with
zelenski is that too many people applaud
him but he doesn't have enough Munitions
enough with rounds of Applause and slavo
crime there's a lot of that but his
troops don't have the weapons they need
do you know why because it's
Applause is for free but a leopard
thousands of Euros why don't we look at
each other in the eye and say we should
be doing more we should be committing to
more we need additional resources to
make sure that though those immobile
tanks are taken out of headquarters and
sent to Ukraine before the spring summer
offensive now this is what we're
discussing and you have a role to play
here my role is to keep member states
United because all sanctions have to be
adopted by unanimity and every single
Euro that comes out or is disbursed from
the European peace facilities based on
unanimity and I have to keep 27 member
states United and believe me it's not
always easy and sometimes we have to
make exceptions and sometimes we have to
accept behavior that we don't like
because we need to stand United and you
can also help in this regard
some of you have said and I accept it
and I assume this responsibility that we
have to do more and do it more quickly
and we have to convince European public
opinion of the need to do this others
have leveled criticism against the
excessive
incrementalism of our Aid and I
understand this criticism if we had done
what we're doing now earlier we would
have saved lives
and it would have been easier to defend
Ukraine
some believe that the solution
is based on stopping military aid and
they're not here to hear my reply I
don't understand
how the left can ask
for us to put an end to military
assistance to Ukraine I I can't get my
head around it I don't understand this
pro-putinism or this extreme naivete
um
on behalf of the left and I do have
friends who believe this
and people that I respect intellectually
but do you really believe that if we
didn't provide Ukraine with the munition
that they need every day every hour to
continue defending themselves do you
really think that that would push Putin
to the negotiating table or would you
not think that it will make them
increase their military offensive please
make sure you've got your feet on the
ground
it's time to wake up uh
every single death caused by a weapon
hurts me deeply but if we want the war
to be shorter the solution is not to
help Ukraine less but to help the more
and in a Swifter manner
the war is dragging out because there's
a stalemate and we have to break this
deadlock and sanctions have to help this
a lot of people have criticized the
effects of the sanctions I'm going to
insist on this if every anyone thoughts
that sanctions would stop the war
machine financially overnight then I'm
sorry you just live in a different world
so there is a slow impact but it's
steady and the figures speak volumes
they speak for themselves last year was
a year that was particularly good for
the Russian treasury but that's because
Energy prices soared and we still
depended on Russia but this year the
figures show that the revenues are
plummeting deficit is going up the trade
balance is suffering and Europe's
technological Independence is
bringing about results
some have said that at the end of the
day it's just NATO that counts if we
want to defend Europe and that raises
once again the debate on NATO and the
Strategic independence of Europe yes
NATO plays a very important role but we
cannot shy away from our own
responsibilities we need to have
military capabilities we didn't have
because we were used to the dream of
peace and that is why our warehouses and
people were not full
but yet the war war is back and we have
to tackle it
now there were mentions of Iran and the
role that Iran plays in backing Russia
but we also have to understand how the
rest of the world thinks and we're going
to see this next week it at the United
Nations
because not everyone thinks the way we
do and not everyone has the same
assessment of the impact of this war I'm
fortunate enough to meet leaders in
Latin America southeast Asia Africa and
many have swallowed the propaganda the
Russian propaganda and the
disinformation that says that
increased food prices and energy price
prices are because of our sanctions and
we have to explain that it's not the
case
food prices go up
when those who are saying that they're
going up are blocking
um
wheat from leaving Ukrainian ports it's
extremely important to educate it's
important to raise awareness because
whether we like it or not in Africa
there is strong anti-colonial sentiment
an anti-imperia a strong
Anti-Imperialist sentiment in Latin
America and that means that a lot a lot
of its inhabitants and leaders see the
war through different eyes
now the reality is multifaceted I'm not
saying we have to impose our reality but
we've got to convince with arguments I
try to bring figures to this debate
because I think that these facts
underpin the arguments that uh our
policies are based on I've never seen a
country
that have had their existential hopes
pinned on Europe so much for those
people who have not had freedom because
of
dictatorships like mine the EU was seen
as a beacon of freedom and for the
future but I've never seen a country
where belonging to the EU hasn't had
this existentialist Dimension as the
Ukraine and that is why in French we
have to provide support to this European
dream even though we know that the road
will be long and winding because to get
peace we need to win the war but when I
say that we have to win the war it
doesn't mean that we forget or that we
will ignore the Diplomatic efforts in
Spanish
these are not contradictory elements uh
we have to do both at the same time
diplomatic efforts and Military a do we
have to think about what Security will
be like in Europe after this is over
what is the role of Europe because I
don't want it just to be China the Us
and other countries to do everything to
bring it into the war we have to think
about how we're going to rebuild a
destroyed Ukraine but we also have to
think about cooperation and
communication on the European continent
will probably need new Russian leaders
that will assume their responsibilities
and assume the responsibility of what
they've done and that will be able to
take their country towards
reconciliation and the common future in
the same way as after the second world
war in Europe we had leaders that were
that managed to push forward with
reconciliation and reconstruction and
that is why we have to double down our
efforts to focus on this everyone you
too this debate has been extremely
important because it has opened my eyes
to the fact that there are still members
of this Parliament that think that what
we're dealing is the wrong thing
and I would like you to tell me what the
alternative is look me in the eyes and
tell me that you accept that Russian
troops will go into Kiev and set up
belarus-like regime because that is
going to be what will happen if we stop
providing military aid to Ukraine and
since we don't want this
and since we don't want this we have to
continue
harnessing our sanctions this slow
acting poison that is undermining the
Russian economy and we have to continue
providing Military Support to Ukraine we
have to not do it very slowly and
steadily but quickly and we have to take
more risks and let me tell you that
we're in the midst of a war we're not
waging the war it's not our young people
who are dying in Kiev but it is a war
that affects us because our security
hinges on the out the outcome of the war
and as president macron said that we
don't have this mentality of a war
economy and we should because otherwise
we have the political decisions that we
have to take and I hope that the
European Parliament will support the
decisions that have to be taken Tim
thank you very much indeed to the high
representative Mr bottle and thank you
of course to everybody who took part in
the debate there was six resolutions put
forward for the end of the discussion
the vote will be tomorrow
now Council and commission statements
next on the Greendale industrial plan
for the net to zero age
let's set the ball rolling on our debate
on behalf of the council the minister
for EU Affairs Roswell
president honorable members commissioner
thank you for the opportunity to address
this